french police have started mass raids of
suspected islamist militants homes
this follows the brutal murder of a
history teacher who showed his people's
caricatures
offensive to muslims thousands of people
gathered in paris on sunday to pay
tribute to him
and denounced the incident as an attack
on the country's
secularist values in the meantime vigils
have been taking place
across france hundreds gathered in
toulouse and the city of lille to decry
violence and support the freedom of
speech
while a national tribute for the teacher
is planned for wednesday
well here's a look at how those tragic
events unfolded
[Music]
one of our compatriots was murdered
because he taught our compatriot was the
victim of an islamist terror attack
[Applause]
[Music]
you the concerned person of russian
nationality
and of chechen origin benefited from a
refugee status
and lived in yevre in the ur he was
unknown to the intelligence services
on a judicial level he's never been
convicted but was known for cases of
damaging public property and gang
violence while still a minor
he asked muslim children to raise their
hand and leave the classroom
he did it my son told me he didn't do it
to discriminate or to hurt he did it to
preserve the children
to not shock them he explained i'd
prefer a few left
because i'm going to show a cartoon of
the prophet of islam
i don't want to shock you
i'm even more shocked that this college
is one i opened when i was the town
mayor
working there was nice and it was
located in a neighborhood without any
problems or violence
i don't think that this act of terror is
a crazy man's deed
but a premeditated act we spoke to
political analyst alessandro bruno now
he believes
france needs a more effective
integration policy
france continues to have
some of the worst integration of uh
muslims uh in their society compared to
other
uh european countries but um you'd be
surprised to know that the majority of
muslims
in europe live in germany where we've
had
relatively fewer cases and um
so there are ideas to be sought you know
within the european union itself on how
to integrate
minorities which france apparently has
not done
the other part of it is if you notice
the pakistani was 18 years old
the chechen man or boy was 18 years old
the the age adolescence of this group
are particularly vulnerable and it's not
just a religion it's
psychology we have isolated and
marginalized youth
which have pretty much nothing to look
up to
well in the case in france i think islam
is is much
it's it's not just nature's
fundamentalism or radicalization
it's it's part of that psychological
process
that um adolescents go through with some
difficulty
at best so when you have um youth in
marginalized
situations um the psychological pressure
uh sociological and psychological is
higher
so that there's a clear evidence
suggesting that
teenagers have to be targeted